let's say that we we're starting with a
population of 1,000 rabbits and we know
that this population is growing at ten
percent per month what I want to do is
explore how that population will grow if
it's growing ten percent per month so
let's set up a little bit of set up a
little table here a little table and on
this left column let's just say this is
the number of months that have gone by
and on the right column let's say this
is the population so we know from the
information given to us that at zero
months we're starting off with one
thousand rabbits now let's think about
what's going to happen after one month
well our population is going to grow by
10% so we could take our population at
the beginning of the month and growing
by 10% that's the same thing as
multiplying by 1.1 you have your
original population and then you grow it
by 10% 1 plus 10% is 1.1 so we can
multiply it by 1 point 1 and that math
we can do in our head it is 1,100 or
1100 but let it let's just write this as
1,000 times 1 point we're not 1.5 times
1.1 now let's think about what happens
as we go to month 2
well it's going to have it's going to be
the population that we started at the
beginning of the month times 1 point 1
again so it's going to be the population
at the beginning of the month which was
that which we have right over there but
then we're going to multiply by 1.1
again or we can just say that this is 1
point 1 squared and I think you see a
pattern emerging after another month the
population is going to be 1,000 times
1.1 to the 3rd power we're just going to
multiply by 1.1 again
and so if you were to go n months into
the future well you could see what's
going to be it's going to be 1,000 times
or being multiplied by 1.1 n times or
1,000 times 1.1 to the nth power and so
we can set up an expression here we
could say look the pop
let's say that the population is P the
population as a function of n as a
function of n is going to be equal to
our initial population our initial
population times 1 point 1 to the nth
power and you might say okay well this
this makes sense it doesn't look like
we're getting crazy numbers but just for
kicks let's just think about what's
going to happen in 10 years so 10 years
would be 120 months so the population at
the end of 120 months is going to be
1,000 times 1.1 to the 120th power and
so let's let me get a calculator out to
do that I cannot calculate 1 point 1 to
120th power in my head
1 point 1 to the 120th power is equal to
that times our initial population so
times 1,000
1 2 3 is going to be equal to roughly 93
million rabbits let me write that down
so we started with 1,000 and we're going
to have approximately 93 million rabbits
93 million million rabbits and so we
grew by a factor of 93 thousand over 10
years so over another 10 years would
grow by 93 thousand times this and so
you quickly realize 10 percent per month
is quite fast and this might seem
extremely fast but this is actually not
outlandish for a population of rabbits
that are not limited by space or
predators or food and if you were to
plot something like this out if you were
to plot the rabbit population with
respect to time you would see a graph
that looks let me draw it so this axis
it is time say in months and this axis
you have your population you have your
population this type of function or this
type of equation
see population I population this is an
exponential function and so your
population as a function of time is
going to look like this it's going to
have this kind of hockey stick J shape
right over here and if you let these
rabbits reproduce long enough they would
frankly take over the planet if they had
enough food and if they had enough space
to do it but as you notice I keep saying
if they have enough food and if they
have enough space the reality in the
world is that there is not infinite food
and infinite space and there are nope
and it isn't the case that there are no
predators or competition for resources
and so there is actually a maximum
carrying capacity for a certain part of
of the environment for a certain type of
species and so what's more likely to
happen what we just described right over
here is exponential growth exponential
growth and why is it called exponential
growth well you notice we are growing by
our the the the input which is time is
being thrown into our exponent and so
that is exponential growth but obviously
you can't have an infinite number of
rabbits or you just can't grow forever
there is going to be some natural
maximum carrying capacity that the
environment can actually sustain and so
the actual growth that you would see
when the population is well below that
carrying capacity it's reasonable to
model it with exponential growth but as
it gets closer and closer to that
carrying capacity it is going to ask
them to up towards it so it's going to
get up towards it but not cross it and
that's just a model there are other
situations where maybe it goes up to it
and it crosses it and then it cycles
around it so these are all different
ways of thinking about it but the
general idea is you wouldn't expect
something to just grow unfettered
forever
now this blue curve which people often
use to model populations especially when
they're thinking about things at
populations once they approach the the
environments carrying capacity this is
this kind of s-shaped curve that is
considered that's called logistic growth
and there is a logistic function that
describes
but you don't have to know it in the in
the in the in the scope of a kind of an
introductory biology there's a logistic
logistic growth and it's described by
the logistic function if you're curious
about it we do have videos on Khan
Academy about logistic growth and also
about exponential growth and we go into
a lot more detail on that but the
general idea here is when populations
are not limited by their environment by
food by resources by space they tend to
grow exponentially but then once they
get close that exponential growth no
longer models it well once they start to
really saturate their environment and
they start to get close to that ceiling
and overall the logistic logistic
function or logistic growth is is a
better model for what is actually going
to happen